[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
go check this out
[Music]
this guy's
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
go check this out
[Music]
chocolate
[Music]
oh
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
swinging
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the third episode of ea
spotlight series that connects you to
the games you love and the people who
make them
i'm nick mizesco and today we are
talking all about madden nfl 22
franchise and the exciting reveal of
scouting i've been waiting for this day
all week long please join me in
welcoming executive producer
sean grady franchise producer tom lichke
and franchise designer moonlight swami
you might know him as andre weingarten
thank you so much for taking some time
out of her day i'm excited
to talk about madden nfl 22 but before
we start
let's get a look at the game that's
coming out madden nfl 22.
[Applause]
you see a lot of teams trying to restart
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
out of the way
[Music]
accepted
this denver crowd making it tough on the
kansas city offense
hard to hear yourself
[Applause]
looking
seven seconds six
are seconds kidding me
now i'm very excited to talk more about
franchise a little bit more about the
scouting
um as a complete total franchise this is
probably my greatest day of the year so
you know the viewers are here to learn
about scouting i know everybody out
there wants to hear about it but
before we get there let's take a step
back for a second let's go to madden 21.
you know you guys just delivered a third
and final huge update
you know you added some features to
franchise mode this is a big year tell
me how you're feeling sean about how
madden 21 went overall
in retrospect yeah i'm feeling really
good it's been a lot of work
a lot of feedback from the community a
lot of work from our team and these guys
over here
uh at the start of the year when we
kicked off mad 21 we got a lot of
feedback from the franchise community
that they were looking for more they
wanted more from their mode
so what we tried to establish with them
is that we hear you we're listening
and uh because our game is a live
service as we've said many times over
the course of this year that we can
deliver more features to you guys
so as you said we we put a road map out
there for three title updates we deliver
some of the top requests
that our fans were asking for like
x-factor customization
a play-off bracket some commissioner
tools on and on we can talk about some
others as well
uh as we arrive at the end of the year i
think we're all really proud of what we
were able to give to the the community
i gotta tell you every multi-user
franchise saw commissioner tools were
like
yes more please thank you i feel like
madden's so unique because not only do
you have
all these different modes from franchise
to ultimate team to
you know superstar ko but you have
different ways to play inside
those modes and is that a constant
discussion of of the guys who just want
to go out and win super bowls the guys
like me who want to
find the right number of where do i set
the parking so that people tune in
and give me some more money like how do
you balance that sort of development
when we build something and it happens
all the time like one of the features
this year
um we redid the hub for franchise for
22.
uh but we got to make sure that works
really well if you're coming at it
player centric or owner-centric or coach
centric and there's just all these
little cases
that we have to figure out in testing
and playing it and bringing in the right
people making sure we're getting that
coverage
and sometimes you'll do stuff that well
this is just straight up
a coach mode or an owner mode thing so
then you have to talk about
all right do we want to do that or is
that do we do something that applies to
everybody i'm curious when we when we're
going into 22 we talk about the changes
of
of uh of franchise mode going into 22
and at 21. were there any changes that
had to be made
in the team itself in terms of you know
just structure
as you moved into madden 22 to tackle
franchise mode i wouldn't say there's
things that had to be made but in the
case of franchise
we wanted to bolster the team we want to
strengthen it with with more
of our talent across madden we wanted to
invest more in
a number of new features which means we
had to put more people onto franchise
which we absolutely did this year
and then we just made sure that we had
the people that were most passionate
about the mode working
in it so that uh the people that are
playing it are the people that are
building it and that's that's kind of
where we end up
uh yeah so the team in some ways built
itself like the the
franchise junkies if you will kind of
re-emerged and
not gonna look at him straight up but
yeah uh could be anyone here
that's gonna be pretty cool for you guys
to work on a mode that's been across so
many different games it's not a new mode
like the yard or ko which are cool but
french has been in madden for so long oh
absolutely i mean
when i started playing back in around
2002 i was seven years old
and what did i play it was only
franchise i mean i play some play now
you know run with michael vick
for you know days on worst kind of
person
everybody hey i'm sorry i'm so sorry
everybody out there
but i mean that's what i did and even if
i didn't know and play now you know run
around with michael vick for
you know days on worst kind of person
everybody
hate i'm sorry i'm so sorry to everybody
out there
but i mean that's what i did and even if
i didn't know exactly what i was
building what i was building as a team
i knew i was having fun and i was
building a team so
as i started getting older and started
investing myself more in the features
i really grew to appreciate what was
there so now
looking back on it it's a perspective of
yes
whether i was eight years old and i
enjoyed it or i'm now 25
and i enjoy it there are features that
are relevant to both
ages that need to be represented because
you want someone who
really doesn't know exactly what they're
doing to still be able to enjoy
themselves but you also want to give
that depth to the people who really want
to dive in can i just say to all the
seven-year-olds out there watching right
now
there is a future there is a future in
madden if you're playing the game right
now
andre is the example come work for us
one day keep playing the game as
somebody who works in the gaming
industry i can tell my parents take that
like video games
was what i was supposed to do exactly uh
i think that's the cool thing also about
franchise mode is that
there's so much depth in it for for the
nerds like me that want to adjust prices
and deal with coaching staffs but it's
also the easiest to sort of explain to
anybody
listen you're taking a team go out and
win a super bowl build that team do
whatever you want to do and
but i'm curious and i guess sean
probably can answer this the best
it feels monumental from the outside i'm
sitting there going how do you even
tackle that was that a challenge at
something
so broad as franchise mode i actually
don't think it is because there's so
many good ideas out there it's really a
matter of then okay prioritizing it and
coming up with a good design that pays
that thing off so you know
we'll talk a bit about staff management
but you can say you're going to do that
how do you build it how do you make it
fun how do you gamify it and make it
interesting that that's the hard part
but the ideas of what you want to go to
attack and the prioritization on the
roadmap i think is a little bit
actually more straightforward there's
plenty of uh opinions on the internet
for sure
breaking news i should find out what
this internet thing is plenty plenty of
opinions out there and then uh so how do
you
take that and distill it and then how do
you maybe are there some people that can
stand up and represent the community
interest and bring them in and that's we
called the design council
and brought in some you know really key
people who we feel like are a good
representative voice
bringing them into the process because
we have all these ideas
and let's go through it and then say how
do we get the best ideas or the right
first ideas so that design console was
part of the approach
that's why we're here today is the like
one of the top things they said made
sense but
it didn't make sense as the first thing
we did so that you know that being
scouting
well you know i'm i'm lucky enough to be
a part of that madden design council and
i've been lucky enough to be involved in
some of these feedback events in the
past
and even at the franchise-specific
events like it was a lot of guys who
played the way similarly that i did
but in the design council you got so
many different voices coming in and i
felt like we were involved
way earlier than in past years was that
a concerted effort and
how did that help in the development of
madden 22. part of it was driven
by the fact that we had to get we we
just knew we
with the sentiment at launch and what we
felt we felt it too
we needed to get going we couldn't wait
for the next product to release to make
progress
um so that gave us the need to bring
people in earlier
like we were talking about the what
we're releasing now
uh back in i think it was september
september october yeah end of september
october yeah and the big fundamental
difference is when you're talking about
it september we haven't
built anything yet and so there's all
kinds of opportunities for change if
you're showing
people stuff in february uh it might
feel like a long ways to what the game's
released
but we're already at things are pretty
locked down and we're finishing things
and polishing things that's a
that's a big difference between the two
stages of development
there's so many places that feedback
come from you talk about the internet
you talk about the design council
but you also have internal feedback
coming in you also have guys just
streaming on twitch who maybe aren't
typing out a twitter post but are still
giving feedback how do you parse through
all that information and find the
nuggets that then you can take and put
into a road map for a game like madden
22.
i would say there's pockets within the
team that um gravitate to a so uh
a specific platform like i like to watch
youtubers so
we have a lot of youtubers you you know
who you are i watch a lot of these guys
i listen i don't comment or anything but
i'm kind of listening to their themes
because
you're a lurker i'm allergic to a marker
yeah yeah there's some uh
guys and gals that are on twitter that
are you know listening to twitter which
i don't go to twitter
as much anymore because it's not quite
as constructive as we might want it to
be with ea in the handle
the feedback finds you in a lot of ways
but i find some of the best feedback on
there
personally because i'm i'm able to
engage with those people in conversation
i think that's really why i still
maintain that presence because i can
have a conversation of
you know someone finds a bug or someone
has feedback and i can say well what do
you mean by that
what settings do you have things like
that so being able to have that back and
forth and then relay it
personally i find that incredibly
valuable and it's worth
the mean tweets and things for all of
that feedback
i appreciate the fact that you're still
out there what are you saying thank you
for taking on twitter cheers
um now i mean i've read the deep dives
i've read the blogs you know we've
talked
there's so many exciting things to come
out coaching staffs talent trees
scouting which we're going to talk about
don't worry we're going to get there
what do you what feature
what edition are you most excited about
in madden 22 sean we'll start with you
i'm going to take uh game planning as
the is my favorite at this point because
i like to uh
uh sorry tom if i took that from you i i
i just left right there just because you
took that thanks a lot
one benefit is it's going to allow you
to game plan against a
real world opponent you know like we
know the data for the kansas city chiefs
from tampa bay buccaneers and how they
play and we're going to use next-gen
stats to see what they do
whatever oh did we win a super bowl yeah
i guess so uh
it hurts yeah uh so i like that so real
world data
gives you information that you can use
to say i'm going to try to shut down
uh you know the deep threat from from
kansas city and then it gives a little
bit of a boost to some of your players
to try to attack that and if that's not
working
i can adjust in half time two things
we've never had before
i find that really compelling but if i'm
playing with some friends online as well
as we progress through a couple of weeks
and through a couple of seasons
their data is going to be logged as well
i'm going to know what their strategies
are and i can game plan against that and
that's just
that's just fun you know like and so
swami may be playing a certain way week
to week
he probably is going to anticipate my
game plan for that and maybe he's going
to switch it up that week
there's a little bit of extra element of
strategy in there so that's my number
one
so mine is uh mine's really franchise
staff though the way franchise
has been in the past like where do you
get your power from in franchises
building your roster
so it's kind of there's this one path to
making a stronger franchise
and we're just adding this whole other
parallel path to say
uh i'm gonna go build up my staff and
change how my my franchise plays week to
week based on
this power curve not just my roster yeah
i mean to echo that i think
franchise staff and maybe focusing more
on the talent trees themselves
are really what i think is my favorite
improvement for the
simple fact that you know all those
different layers
get kind of that umbrella treatment of
we can really enhance
beyond the system and give you the
opportunity to shape your
your entire franchise differently every
single time
i mean to have over 60 different talents
with all different types of power
to them and then the ultimate talents
really have
distinct power that change the way that
your franchise may function
whether it be giving more focus players
i know that's something that
tying into the weekly strategy uh three
focus players always kind of felt
restrictive
because i just didn't feel like enough
players were getting the attention that
they needed to become
special so being able to expand that up
to six with the with that talent
i mean that is an entirely different way
to handle your weekly strategy make you
excited
to jump into that so that's your
favorite really not scouting
guys we're teasing scouting someone has
to say scouting i mean
we have a whole discussion about
scouting it's really interesting being
in that group because
you know there's something that i might
care about from a multi-user franchise
that somebody who's just a solo player
doing content for example
they've never even like bothered to
think about like commissioner tools i
don't think anybody's in a
in a single player franchise cares about
commissioner tools they are the
commissioner and the only player but at
the end of the day
all the multi-users i know in all the
multi-user franchises were so pumped
when commissioner tools got into the
game you thought it was christmas day
yeah our philosophy is uh it's your
franchise it's your game
you choose how much of any given thing
you want or don't want
so you can have the experience you want
so yeah the way that i look at that is
we're building something to enhance your
experience and i don't want it to become
a detractor for you
because you're locked into one way of
playing that might not mesh with your
overall style
you know i know sometimes i have a
league where i just want to face the
computer i just want to blow them out i
just want to have fun and not worry
about
any level of simulation and there's
other leagues where i want a competitive
hardcore experience that is a totally
different environment for me
yeah i'm just looking for a multi-user
league that'll let me win a super bowl
that's all i'm looking for
um as somebody who works in the
competitive sphere i gotta say it's
it's really cool to see these guys who
are playing ultimate team on the
competitive level
they're getting into franchise mode
because they're looking for just
something different outside of the grind
that is the competitive game
and they're loving starting up these
leagues with their friends and
everybody's picking a team and they're
dealing with trades they're
you're seeing different people get into
franchise mode and i didn't realize that
was something that was possible i
thought everybody just played franchise
mode because
that's how everyone got into madden yeah
i think what the biggest gift we can
give people is the ability to walk away
with a story
and that's what franchise naturally can
do is you know it's the story of my
league or my team or whatever it is and
regardless of how you play day to day
it's it's always kind of fun
to go and build your story and walk away
with uh what was this version of my
franchise
and that's actually one of the things
we're hoping to continue to to push and
evolve as we build our franchises
if i make the exact same choices from
the beginning
with two leagues hopefully uh
they'll play out differently right
because you know maybe i'll throw
five passes to my third round draft pick
receiver and i'll get us
a season engine event which says okay
now it's about him
it's a breakout moment what do we do and
we start building the franchise that
direction
so more of that in the future is
definitely where we want to go no
what a catch look at the move by cook
are you kidding me
i think it's time to get into scouting
when can we expect to get our hands on
it
all right we're excited to get this in
the hands of our players is going to
kick off our live service continuous
development for this year for
franchise so it's coming early in the
season we're targeting
this first one for september uh first
big beat
of you know three seemed to be a cadence
that worked for us last year
like three groups of uh content that
we've delivered through the course of
the year so
we'll be looking at that same approach
this year i know i'm excited i wonder
who we should talk to
about scott don't look around we're
staring right
at you andre we're dying tell us what we
can
expect uh with uh the revamp of scouting
all right so that deep sigh really makes
me excited because i know that means
this for years i've been waiting a long
time for this
so scouting as a whole is being revamped
obviously you'll still be able to scout
players but the way that we go about it
is entirely different
we're moving away from the scouting
point system where you have
a bucket of points each week and then
you spend it on players
this is more making key decisions
throughout the season
that progress every single player on
your board at different points
so you start things off essentially by
getting a baseline scouting on every
player in
your class you know this guy runs fast
he can
move well he's strong and they sounded
like mel keiper right now he's got
quiet hands one of the big goals i had
was
i wanted to add complexity to the
feature but i wanted to remove some of
the tediousness of it
so you don't have to go in every single
week and feel like you're missing
something if you don't
but there are key decision points that
you're going to want to interact with
because that'll shape how your board
basically evaluates itself over the
course of a season
so you'll be able to pick a position per
each of your now
four area scouts and a national scout
rather than just being a scouting
department
you have individual scouts with
strengths and weaknesses so i might have
a guy who
specializes in scouting quarterbacks
yeah and you're going to send them out
the area scouts to
one of four regions on the map you know
some regions have more schools than
others so we kind of
cut them off a little bit at the past so
each region has its merit to send a
quality scout
and you'll be able to assign your scouts
at the start of each season
based on a preliminary big board and the
big board
is changing in itself it's no longer
just
you know here's all the players ranked
we're treating it more as a media big
board
so a player has a few really good games
in a row right
and you see a news blurb pop up that
this player just
you know he's been dominant you're gonna
see that he's going to
move up the draft board so the ai itself
is going to draft players based on the
changes in perception and evaluation of
the players
instead of it being that you know you
find this guy in the fifth round
and he's the best player in the class
and he just sits there that's not going
to happen anymore
it's really going to be a lot more that
if you find that player and you really
key in on them
at different scouting events you'll be
able to
get gather a large amount of information
but it comes at a cost and the cost is
awareness
for the media so you send your national
scout and we call it focus scouting
this is one of the biggest milestones in
terms of report completion that you're
going to get
and when you do that the media is going
to be aware that you are attending this
player's game
so if it's a sixth round player and
you're sending your national scout the
guy who you want the best report from
to a sixth round players game for that
guy
they're going to be like whoa whoa this
guy can't have
is what you're saying i can't secretly
scout anyone you can
scout in secret but you might have to
sacrifice a little bit of information
right
if i'm trying to get that full
completion that's basically me sending
my national scout in the front row and
everyone knows that i'm sitting there
to scout this guy yeah exactly and you
know you'll have private workouts
that you'll be able to do same same
premise where you'll have a few players
that you can bring in for those private
workouts
and that'll give you a big boost in the
report completion
but there's additional layers to it so
that big board
ebbs and flows and there'll be mock
drafts well we right now we have it
scheduled for five mock drafts over the
course of the season so as draft
position changes
so does this so if you need to make a
decision on
oh man i'm not gonna be able to get to
pick 16 and they're looking at this
player and this position
i might have to jump them or i have to
change my plans on who i'm looking at
so the entirety is more information
my legit my first thought with this was
in a multi-user league
is it possible for somebody to throw
somebody off their scent to sit there
and go like
i know like for example if i'm the
dolphins and i sort of know where i'm
gonna be and i know
the bengals are right behind me and
they're gonna be drafting and i know
that they're gonna be
you know wanting to jump me if i'm
looking for a quarterback can i start
scouting
offensive lineman to try to throw him
off that oh you don't need to jump me
you're fine stay there
uh theoretically yes thank you i'm
looking to be a real jerk in my league
so i i i appreciate that
that's one of those things that we
talked about earlier um building it in a
way that
people who want to go that layer deeper
be a multi-player leagues or whatever
yeah that there's that deeper design
there that's a good
solid approach i think so absolutely and
and
we've talked with former nfl personnel
former scouts
uh media members who do scouting all
sorts of different groups of people
about the scouting process and the one
thing that always comes back to me is
the aggregation of information is the
hardest part
of scouting because you can understand
every single layer of a player's skill
set but if you don't piece it together
properly to make that full picture
it doesn't matter and that's where a lot
of people get tripped up you can see
this guy's fast or this guy has a big
arm but if you don't understand that
well yeah he has that big arm
and he can throw deep but because he
doesn't have the the mental processing
or the awareness for our game's sake
then he's not going to be that guy
that you would expect or that he was in
college so
aggregation is not going to be exact
you might not find their exact true
talent range
and it's a range this year instead of
saying this guy's a first round pick
it'll be you know round one to round two
or top five
you know those blue chip players those
are clear cut and as you get later in
the draft
that range is wider so we want to give
you as much information as possible
without overwhelming
and i mean i'm overwhelmed right now i'm
not gonna lie this is this is
unbelievable i'm so excited for this
what would you say was the most
important thing for you to get right
when it came to scouting
uh obviously the information itself what
what we're giving you and how we're
giving it to you was really important
but the loop of what are the
reveal milestones what are your action
points
right when do you need to engage with
this system and
can you engage with it when you don't
need to so
for me i staggered it throughout the
season because
i wanted to make sure that there was
information relevant
for you as a player at each stage of the
season and then the postseason hits
and you can focus on your playoff games
you don't have to worry about scouting
at all
off season comes back around boom it
hits you back up again
and that's when you really start diving
in you get the combine the pro days the
private workouts
so making sure that you have something
to do at all the relevant points
especially when the season lulls
and making sure that it stays out of
your way when it doesn't need to be
there
but you can always go in and look that
scouting tab will never disappear
my first one my favorite thing is these
guys work on the game and they are
locked into this discussion
these guys know about i'm locked in
because i know these guys are listening
on the edge of their seats um is there
something built into the game that's
going to prevent me from
signing all the best scouts and turning
the cleveland browns into the dynasty
that they truly deserve to be don't tell
me otherwise
i describe it as there are tiers to your
scouting department that you need to
fill
so rather than it being i have a certain
amount of points or i'm just going to
sign all the best scouts
you have let's say three tiers
and that really modifies how much uh
additional bonus you get when scouting a
position of expertise
so it's really not that you're picking
the best scouts you're picking
the scouts that are most logical for you
but they have two positions of expertise
and
that's going to be a little bit of a
teaser for something that we're going to
be dropping in the future
but it's going to be there and the
second one is grayed out
you'll be able to access that at some
point post launch
but we're not going to get too much into
that so you're picking
ultimate teas right there something
that's coming out something later of
teasing
teasing so but the idea is that that
expertise is really what's driving you
well we know andre he's like me he's
he's a
hardcore franchise player i'm curious
from you guys do you guys feel like
there's something
applicable here in scouting to the
casual fan is this something that's
valuable to somebody just picking up
trying to win a super bowl
so a casual fan when we asked them and
said well what do you want out of
franchise
well i want to win super bowls and so
how do you win super bowls you build
your roster up over years
it's how do you build your roster you
add players scouting needs to be really
powerful
and accessible in terms of i can make my
franchise better each year like we said
earlier you know kind of monitor and see
how
players use it and if we see some of
those casual players going in
uh then we're doing something right and
if not then we can continue to iterate
on the design we
i think almost kind of designed it for
our core franchise player first because
that's who we're
we're hearing loud and clear from you're
welcome uh but of course we do want
those other casual players that still
want to build a roster in the way that
they want to build it to use it and so
we monitor and you know iterate
long term you know my my game looping
franchise is much more
uh go in make a couple decisions play
the game um and
scouting in the pa right now feels like
well it even warns me like if i don't go
spend those points they're lost they're
lost
so i feel like okay i got to go in i got
to do that even though i
it's a little bit nebulous to me what's
happening i still have to do it or i'm
losing
power and the one thing i don't want to
do is lose power because i feel like i'm
just that much further from one of those
super bowls
absolutely and i think that's one of the
other considerations that we had
where if you choose not to interact with
the system it'll
essentially autopilot for you and it'll
treat it like the computer is doing it
rather than costing you
for not interacting with it what you'll
take a pass on is that granular control
like you'll be
bending your scouting department towards
a certain need if you just like building
a roster and just going through season
after season
you can still get that as long as you
spend just a little bit of time right at
the front
right it's not like it's week three
anymore it is pre-season
week one that you're jumping into
scouting for the first time get it right
away as opposed to having to wait for
that yeah and your touch point literally
is assigning which
region you don't have it your scouts
will go out and do their thing
immediately you don't have to pick a
single player all you need to do is
evaluate the big board
see a mock draft say where you want them
to go and then
let them go for the entire preseason you
could skip the preseason and you're not
going to miss
a thing yeah i'm just curious like you
know i feel like this is the value of
sitting down with you guys and talking
with you in the spotlight series is
being able to talk with the guys who
make the game and i think
the biggest thing i i think that is
important to convey is
why and i guess my question is why have
you guys made such a focus on
servicing franchise post launch and
making it a live service
you know gamers are 12 month of year
gamers now it's
in the past it would be i'd pick up
madden and play it for a couple months
or on launch and
it's really hardcore you might play it
longer but now it's that's not the
expectation anymore and
and we hold ourselves to a standard of
we want it to be something that
you'll do you know a good chunk of the
year and have it be interesting and
fresh
we've already been doing it for years
inside madden with but it's primarily
been through ultimate team so
really it's laddering franchise up to
that same sort of standard
um knowing that that's not the easiest
thing in the world to do because
ultimate team was built to be good at
that and franchise was built to be good
at
providing a season in a sandbox and it
is a different live service than
ultimate team yeah right ultimate team
you have messaging every week almost
daily so you know
you're going to miss some of that
day-to-day messaging that
i know that some people have been
clamoring for but that's just kind of
the nature of the mode it is a
it is such a large sandbox that it's
just not
as modular on a day-to-day basis but it
can be modular and we're
really emphasizing that on a yearly
basis
ultimate team actually like absorbs
new content and stand out performances
yeah
and it just gets added into whatever
what you've already built there
franchise not like that
i already have a story that's in
progress so maybe we would add
a scenario to the season engine that
says you know
uh tom brady suddenly actually is still
good
so you know let's let's not let's not go
outside the realm of reality it pains me
like i didn't know i was walking into
this today right like after watching my
packers there's one person here that's
really happy about this
i know you know who you are who designed
this
but but we would bring that in via uh
additional storytelling
add to the story you already have an
ultimate team it's just like oh no
there's just a cool new player that had
a breakout thing and yeah i want to add
that to my sandbox
it's just replacing right yeah which you
can't do you don't want to overwrite all
of everything you did
if we modified tom brady because he had
a great weekend season
and you're in year you know six and he's
now 55 years old and he's
if i'm the box owner i want tom brad to
be really good like the only person who
wants is the one who has
um that player um now i i think i can
ask this
um is there is there any anything you
can tease that's coming to
franchise post you can ask i'm asking
i am there are things we're thinking
about for sure uh
we we put a lot of energy towards uh
resetting the baseline in terms of the
feature
set with uh you know franchise staff and
the weekly strategy where we haven't put
as much energy right yet
is maybe in terms of free agents and
things like that so that's an area that
we
think about and talk about is trades and
what not
is there something we can do there what
is the relevant information at different
points in the year that we can
raise to you to make you care about not
just your team
but kind of expand you out of that that
bubble that is kind of described of
your team-centric franchise yeah give
you that make the league have life as
opposed to my team have life like make
the league have history it goes back to
we want it to be your story and for it
to be your story the league has to be a
big character in there and the other the
other teams and the other
people in a multiplayer league have to
be part of that story um the hub is
the most complex screen madden's ever
had um
just with the amount of information that
it brings to you all at once
um so we've spent a lot of energy on it
and we'll continue
to spend energy on it like how can we
make your franchise more usable more
powerful
and more able to tell that story is a
big part of it so i would just add
everything's on the table you know
that's the good news as we said earlier
we're listening to the community we want
to hear feedback as we get into the
launch of the season
i think we've delivered two of the top
three most requested features in staff
management scouting you know so there's
some others out there and
we'll hear more as we go into the launch
window and we'll figure it out
together yep it's the summer we still
have time yeah
we might even let you to come back in
the fall again to talk about oh thanks
well i i think the question that
everybody is wondering is have you guys
talked about
what you're going to call men 2025
because you've already used the madden
25 thing is that discussion happen
well we're going to talk to the
community about that okay good good
feedback
sure there will be suggestions well
gentlemen it has been an absolute
pleasure talking about madden franchise
but i can't wait and i
hope that people at home are as excited
as i am and thank you for joining us
today for this exciting look at madden
nfl 22 franchise
and what's to come this year with
scouting make sure you stay up to date
to the making madden podcast
where you'll learn about upcoming
franchise features coming this madden
season
more will come from the ea play live
spotlight series in the next few days
you can also follow at ea on twitter or
go to ea.com for the latest updates
and don't forget ea play live is july
[Music]
22nd
[Music]
you